I'm going to show you how the remainder
theorem ends up being useful and
actually it has kind of like a brother
which is even more useful than that but
I need to get to it through here okay so
let's have a look at this polynomial now
it's a bit of a gross mess do you
remember we used to look at these things
you'd be like I don't know Densmore save
me right and like what do I do with this
thing at the moment it's in a messy form
it's all expanded it's very hard to work
with but not that I'm saying this is
what it's actually equal to if I gave
you another cubic like this I don't know
if I gave you a cubic like this you'd be
like oh I know how to graph this I can
graph most of the shape I know where the
x-intercepts are gonna be I can work out
where the y-intercept is going to be and
I can draw it right and suppose that
this guy were you like gross what'd I do
with this right well the answer to what
do you do with this is we can use the
remainder theorem to turn this guy into
that okay we can take this garbled mess
and we can actually see some structure
in there now if you have a look at 5a
they say show that this guy is divisible
by and then there's a they provide you
with a couple of factors let's just have
a look at one of them okay so I think
the X minus three X minus three so what
it means for like 32 to be divisible by
eight means when you divide what's the
remainder when you get 32 divided by
eight maybe I should ask what's the
answer when you get 32 divided by eight
it's just four and when you say four
it's because there is no remainder
there's no like leftover bit right so to
say something is divisible means there's
no remainder now have a look at this
right there suggests saying this guy is
divisible by this which should mean if
we were to divide through if we were to
go through all of that then the
remainder should be zero if it is
visible right now I'm like but if that's
all I really care about the remainder
then I don't need to go through this
whole process I had a process that could
get me straight to the remainder I just
check that which is the whole point of
the remainder theorem so see this guy
here this is my X minus a so what value
of a should I try out just three okay
let's give this a go P of three this is
what I'm going to evaluate exactly right
because it's three and not negative
three because of how I wrote
this see this it's X take away that
number not x+ you'll see what happens in
a minute we the other one is an X plus
and we'll give that a go okay so let's
just show that this is true okay
I am now just evaluating I'm going
through this step here okay so I'm gonna
put my threes in everywhere I see my X's
so let's just write it down first and
then you can actually help me evaluate
it this is chapter 4 yeah in the Utah
book that you know this is Cambridge
okay do we use nothing freaking
screaming yeah okay Richard English okay
so I'm straight you already told me the
first one 3 cubed is 27 can someone take
over and surround minus 8 times 8 times
9 is 72 very good Stan Lee key tell me
the next one you can just look at it
it's up here unless my writing is that
bad oh my case sure 27 plus my 18 yep
I've got oh let's see here yeah so my 10
it again is it gonna it's 50 its 54
after you after you do all of it right
yeah yeah you're you're just doing a few
the steps in between I think if I did 27
plus 27 plus 18 I'd get 72 right and so
I've got 72 takeaway 72 so you get zero
and your calculator can double-check
that if you like right so wait a second
what have we just establish I went
through and I tried out P of three all
right and I got this guy out a remainder
of zero so you're like oh that means the
thing I started with this X minus a
which in our case was X minus 3 it's
divisible it doesn't leave a remainder
behind okay and in fact see this right
if you get 0 that that doesn't mean like
if your remainder is 0 that means you
actually can divide through nicely
that's its other version of the
remainder theorem which we call because
it's about getting factors it's called
the factor theorem they're kind of like
two sides of the same coin when the
remainder is 0 what you have what you
started with is a factor now they asked
us to test out another one what was
younger if you asked us to the test
X
something right X plus one thank you now
see this guy here I want to write this
in a form that's X minus a there's a
plus in there so I'm gonna write this as
X minus hmm I turn this into a minus
I've got to compensate for that with
another minus sign right so that's
negative one
do you see our X plus 1 and X take away
negative 1 are the same thing so see
this guy here that's the a that I'm
gonna test out can you pop it in and
find out what P of negative 1 is go
through show the working see what you
get now hopefully you got there right
and by the way I'm just going to catch
up because I can't just say oh that's
equal to zero I actually have to show
that the question itself says it says
show that right so I need some working
here so that's why I'm going to go to or
through and make sure I actually get
this and thankfully it doesn't take too
much working to actually get there
negative 1 or cubed negative 1 what
happens in here yeah this just becomes 1
so I get a minus 8 left behind what
happens to the 9 in the negative 1 minus
9 plus 18 and you can see oh this is
going to be the 18 sorry the negative 18
plus 18 so I do get 0 like a got before
okay so this is the remainder theorem
when the remainder is 0 in both cases
and if we have a remainder oops if we
have a remainder of 0 we're like oh I'm
actually divisible this is a factor
right I won't have some like leftover
bits like this so I can actually take
this guy and divide through by each of
these and I'm going to get something
without any leftover bits okay now let's
just quickly do this together this time
I actually am going to do the division
now that I know that they'll divide
through so go ahead and write with me
we'll do this one first X minus actually
I take it back let's do this one first
and I'm gonna ask you in a minute
why I chose this one rather than the
other one you really could do either
they both will work but you have a think
about why this might be more useful
here's my dividend
okay
and now the algorithm begins what's my
first thing that I write down x squared
all right at the top and can someone
take it from Shane Bobby what am I going
to do with that x squared yep multiply
the entire what the entire divisor over
here so I'm gonna get X cubed plus just
the x squared very good okay and at this
point I'm gonna do my subtraction right
minus x squared to take away that x
squared gives me minus 9x squared and
then there's an X now what because
that's how many times the X fits into
this guy over here so now I'm going to
multiply back which gives me this yep
watch out for things and then I've got
this and I'm subtracting a negative so
what happens when I do 9x takeaway
negative 9x yeah watch out those signs
right this is going to be actually 18x
isn't it and then the last thing I've
got that 18 hanging out down there and
this looks promising doesn't it right I
divide through how many times am I gonna
fit plus 18 and you're like oh this is
what I was expecting
before never Amanda this is the thing we
knew we were expecting right so what
I've got now is this original polynomial
X cubed by the bar it's lovely isn't it
right it's like yes it works right so I
think I'm gonna need a little more space
I'm gonna write this line here for this
particular polynomial here we go so I've
got here's my P of X X cubed minus 8x
squared plus 9x plus 18 what was the
divisor I just went by X plus 1 that
thing at the front he comes my quotient
the answer that I ended up with x
squared minus 9x plus and then my
remainder here is plus 0 so I'm actually
kind of done right now having a look at
this you're like oh I know what
do with that like this is a quadratic
I've done lots and lots of these I can
already factorize it in fact you've even
already done half of the work you know
what one of the numbers is negative
three the question actually hand it to
you what's the other number going to be
six negative six negative three negative
six they're going to add together to
give that and then the negatives will
cancel to give that so in this
particular case we're actually going to
pull it for a second and say later on we
will graph but for now let's just take
stock of what we've done okay we use the
remainder theorem to be able to test out
hey do these things divine or not
suppose the question did not tell you
each of these things right didn't tell
you and you're like you need to try and
work this out yourself I'm gonna try
some numbers I'm gonna put numbers in
until I get something that gives me a
remainder of zero that's an actual
factor and that's why we call that
version the factor theorem and then once
you've done that you can actually divide
through now before I asked you I could
have divided by X minus three or I could
have divided by X plus one and I
actually changed my mind Midway as I
wrote
has anyone worked out why I chose one
over the other what's the thing that
that's a good question I when I was
dividing I was writing this line here
right and I was like I'm gonna divide
this original big gross polynomial by
either this guy or this guy and I really
can choose I'd get the right answer this
guy I get this out at the end whichever
way I where it's like I've got two parts
to drive down left or right and I chose
to drive down that path this is the one
I chose can anyone suggest to why this
might have been helpful guy what are you
thinking what is really easy to multiply
by it's like the easy well suppose zero
would be slightly easier but one is next
easiest right plus one gives me this and
this and this and I hardly even have to
think there's one other thing that's
useful as well it's not just one it's
plus one right see how this this is
negative sign up here and you guys have
seen how easy it is to trip over
yourself when you've got negatives
subtracting negatives it's like I'm just
giving myself a headache right so if you
can choose choose easy things for
yourself rather than hard things
okay so let me get pause for a second
okay we've just let this remainder
theorem if you have a polynomial any
polynomial you like and if you put into
there a value like two or negative one
like so you'll get some number at the
end like say five what would that number
mean if you test that out that would be
the remainder if you divided by what
would be the divisor that corresponds
this guy X minus two see that see right
there that's a bit of a tricky thing
that's a video weird thing to remember
but that's why we wrote this down what
if I divided by or sorry what if I tried
this out I've got that what would that
mean yeah if I divided by this then the
remainder would be this so this is the
remainder theorem right what if I tried
something out and then I got zero what
would that mean they're like ah there's
no remainder right it's like oh I divide
evenly that's not just a special that's
not any no but that's a factor and so we
call that guy the factor theorem now
this is a little there's a lot of
algebra here right you guys are really
comfortable with graphing and the upside
of this is as string anticipated you're
going to get to the graphing array
that's kind of the big point of this but
you do have to wade through some algebra
to get there